[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is tae-soo zhang an associate professor
of law at Yale Law School he works on
comparative legal history specifically
economic institutions in modern China
and early modern Western Europe he has
published a number of articles and
essays and academic journals and popular
outlets and is the current president of
the International Society for Chinese
law and history today we'll talk with
professor Zhang about his new book the
laws and economics of Confucianism
kinship and property in pre-industrial
China and England which recently
received the Gatos Smith International
Book Prize from the Macmillan Center
welcome professor Zhang well thank you
it's a pleasure to be here let's start
with an overview of your book tell us
about it sure so the book can be
described on two different levels at the
more kind of like broader thematic level
it's an attempt to inject a certain
measure of cultural analysis into this
field that you can probably define as
like global economic history it's a
field that has since the 1980s been
moving steadily away from kind of like
traditional web area and cultural
analysis towards a more kind of
materialistic and functionalist economic
mindset and the argument that I want to
push in the book is that you can only
take that so far before you're willing
to expand Tory factor is that I demand
culture excavations themselves the
second level is basically I I became
intrigued with this kind of
institutional comparison between early
modern Chinese and English proper
institutions in that despite the fact
that China was known to be like the kind
of oriental oppressive hierarchical
Society it turned out that for much of
this kind of pre industrial phase China
had what you might call more egalitarian
property institutions the England in the
simple sense that Chinese property
institutions did a better job of
protecting the basic interests of small
holders and the work of households in
the rural countryside then their English
and functional English comparative
comparisons did now the way that these
three things merge together is that if
you start digging back into the the
origins of these institutions it turns
out they have much to do with the way
that kind of social culture defines
social hierarchies and it had much to do
with the nature of kinship weaselly
covenant more individualistic society in
england and so the argument was that
these institutions were kind of like a
bridge between cultural origins of a
certain kind and in certain kinds of
economic outcomes right so the in the
end the causal link that's argued for in
the book is that you have something that
you could call Confucian kinship
hierarchies in Confucian family culture
that made the allocation of societal
power and of like when you could conquer
a global communal polical power in the
rural countryside in china somewhat more
egalitarian than what you find in early
modern England which in which basically
how much power you go to was tied to how
much wealth you had which basically
meant that all the you know elite
political elites in any given community
were pretty much the richest people in
the community now so that meant that you
know when people began to negotiate
proper institutions especially proper
into the proper institutions that had a
certain kind of a class-based class
oriented elements institutions that is
that were divided they caused divisions
in society based on how much wealth you
had the negotiation in China was a bit
more equitable between repeating rich
and poor because it was possible in the
Chinese countryside for poor for poor
people to rise to quite high political
status whereas that was virtually
impossible in England and so because of
that simple political economy you have
more poor from the proper institutions
in China than you do in England now then
this has a further economic consequence
is the most straightforward and simple
of which is you actually have a vast
vastly higher level of land accumulation
and early modern England you know a
basic status like what roughly fifty
years before industrialization in both
the countries of the top ten percents in
the English countryside owns something
like 85% of the land whereas
chyna the comparable number wasn't think
40% no that still seems like a lot of a
lot of inequality and a lot of a lot of
accumulation but that difference was
huge enough to have pretty pamification
x' for the economic trajectories of both
societies okay so I would like to unpack
some of what you had just said but I am
curious this is your first book what led
you to write it well so unlike you know
a lot of scholars like history because
they just like history and they like
historical methods I liked history and I
like being a scholar because there were
certain questions that I wanted to
answer so I'm more of a kind of an issue
driven person than a methodology
different person or a field room a
person the the question is that's always
driven me up to this point is basically
what happened so you know why did China
decline in the 18th and 19th century
relative to you know Western European
powers and then later to Japan because
if you want to understand the shape of
modern Chinese society in the shape of
modern Chinese history that is the
fundamental starting point for
everything that's know it's the it's the
cornerstone and that basically shapes
everything that comes afterwards so that
was what got me into this kind of thing
this question about the great divergence
and but the thing is like you know if
you want to write about the great
divergence you can't just start off and
do a PhD and then write a book about the
great divergence no one's going to take
you seriously because they're dealing
what typically topic we're at the front
so there have to be like a series of
stepping stones before through which you
establish credibility and also kind of
establish some basic cornerstones of
your arguments that you can then use and
perhaps like a third or fourth book as
material for broader synthesis so this
is designed to be it the first book of
probably what it's going to be like a
three book series that will lead
ultimately to the question of you know
were there say legal and then cultural
origins of the great divergence so
that's what got me into this entire
thing okay let's talk about your
methodology tell us about it because I
know you did a lot of different things
right um so as a basic matter of
empirics
the there are a couple of different
levels of mature that you have to have
in this kind of work or so there's an
appears an economic level there's an
institutional slash legal level and then
there's the cultural stuff I'm at the
economic level I use the same resources
as pretty much everyone else does right
the kind of land service conducted in
the late seeing in the early republic
whatever quantitative data that we have
that reaches back sometimes to the early
1700s and so on and so forth
for the institutional stuff there's
there there's increasingly a lot of
material being available the previously
was not even as recent it's like ten
years ago so traditional people used say
the first national archives the first
national historical archives in Beijing
to pull up central level court cases and
laws and regulations and so on and so
forth and I use those two but much more
interest in me for me there are a large
number of like local cases that are
being made available and local case
archives that have been made that have
been made available through County
Archives and universities Department
with the the partner with the County
archives over the past pretty much 10
years and so that from the bulk of the
institutional material I form
partnerships with a few local kind of
agents in China that then got me in
touch with the universities in our local
County Archives they had this kind of
material now that also begins to give
you some what's your deal with the
cultural question because now the cases
insofar as they reveal patterns of local
power allocation or local social
hierarchies help with that then there is
the directly kind of more cultural
evidence there are kind of detailed
rural surveys conducted in the 1930s by
various parties Japanese and Chinese
then there are things like lineage
registries and family records and so on
and so forth
so you pull these things together you
find a kind of protocol heesu narrative
based on all three of these things as
for the analytical methodology I'm kind
of a jack-of-all-trades so like I don't
really believe in disciplinary
boundaries in a very strong sense my
general belief is that if you have a
question and the question demands any
number of methodological tools you just
gotta learn the tools you shouldn't be
confined to what you
you based on your ethological well
theoretical for toolkits you should
always be in the business of trying to
expand it theoretical toolkit so I have
some background in economics some
background in political science and
sociology some background of legal
theory and you know theoretically the
book draws upon all those things
historically mainly it's like as a
historian the the fundamental charges to
be empirically rigorous so that's the
starting point but at some point you
have to get at the reticle analysis and
there I'm more aggressive than perhaps
most people in my field and trying to
bring this kind of like
multidisciplinary approach to how you
actually use the data let's talk about
the time periods because I know it's a
little bit different for China versus
England and also talk about the
geographic
you know England is much smaller
obviously than all of China so talk
about that as well right so
geographically exactly as you say
England isn't much you know England is
basically a couple of provinces in China
so I I did the cheap thing which was the
focus on the parts of the China that
were economically most advanced most
stable most kind of like historically
well settled and which then tended also
the yield the most of data right so this
happened to be the lower Young's and
then if you wanted to kind of like add a
separate kind of comparison set that was
a little bit bit a little bit different
within the confines of Chinese so
economic development I threw in North
China as a separate comparison set as
well timewise so essentially right
because I'm not quite yet in the
business of explaining that we're
divergence I can take us take a bit more
freedom and how I define my time periods
and for me the the overwhelming concern
was not put these two countries at the
same point in time but rather put them
at a point in time put them at different
points in time where they were most
functionally comparable right and so to
me this was basically at the century
before industrialization China and us
realized pretty much after 1950
England industrialised around after 1750
and so the approximate time periods
would then be you want to look at you
know 1650 to something heavy for England
you want to look at 18th the post typing
period in your 18
sixty-five to nineteen forty something
in China now the the benefit of that is
that you know these are these are
periods in which the countries both
countries had a huge number of like
functional similarities they were
predominantly agrarian and they were
relatively stable these in the countries
in the world to be stable they had you
know they were proud they were private
property oriented they were
commercialized highly commercialized in
both contexts there were proto in the
streets of proto does for development in
both countries there was a significant
urbanization there was a market-based
proto does report on production and
urban centers in both the countries and
so a lot of the basic kind of like
functional similarities that you need to
do CLE comparison were there these
periods where as if you had thrown China
and England at pretty much the same
period of time that a lot of things
would be going on and wish no this is I
like what society would be relatively
stable whereas the other would not be
and so on and so forth okay let's talk
about some of your findings particularly
in the I believe the first and second
chapters you talk about mortgages in
England versus at the and correct me if
I'm saying this incorrectly
Dianne's and China yeah tell us about
that right so so the the course official
comparison and that I draw is between
like what how do these two societies
regulate the ways in which you
essentially mortgage land the reason why
I focus on these on these kinds of
institutions is that frankly speaking
for most of their parts of property law
the two countries are pretty much
broadly similar if they were privatized
you had pretty secure private property
rights against from neighbors and
against the state it was not easily
violated like you know it certainly
wasn't one country had secured private
property rights whereas the other
country did it it was not come like a
Doug North kind of traditional
institutional economics kind of story
now that said for the places that did
exhibit differences the to the two sets
of institutions that mattered most of
the interests of lower income households
or actually mortgage institutions and
then and then tenancy institutions right
the reason for this is that you know
very often if you're lower income family
you have to rent out now from a larger
landlord so that
we're about tennis institutions whereas
no there's a clearly there's a clear
class-based difference in what landlords
want out of tenancy institutions and
what tenants wants from a tenant swans
extreme levels of security they want
nowhere run stable runs landlords often
want the opposite they want to have the
freedom to invent tenants and raise
rents and so on and so forth
and the same thing applies also a
lineage applies also in mortgages where
mortgages are you know if you're a
landlord that has quite a bit of cash
and you want to go out and get land you
basically could either just buy it
outright or you could you know offer
loans to the small holder take Aslan as
collateral and when the small holder
fail to repay you within a certain time
period you will just get the lab where
this is how mortgages work in this era
and so you know how much and either side
has an incentive just like offer to
purchase the land out why it depends on
what kinds of institutions you have in
the mortgage context because if the
mortgage law allows landlords to kind of
get land on the cheap where you offer
some of these cents on the dollar as a
loan the guy feels to repay and you get
the entire land you actually save 30
cents on the dollar right so so the more
that happens the less smooth and
landlords are to directly buy land and
the more will more willing tenants
harness that work they sell that now if
on the other hand you have extremely
favorable mortgage institutions
favorable in the sense that they protect
the interests of small holders and make
it really hard for landlords the seized
land under conditions of defaults then
you know small holders will assist there
like when I offer my land I only want to
offer it as like a mortgage collateral
and I won't let you buy it outright so
from that perspective right you know
like mortgage has enormous employers law
has enormous implications and how much
kind of like circulation there is within
a land based economy like how much land
flows flows between small holders and
large landowners and therefore to write
it directly has huge impact on how much
land like large non boards are able to
accumulate and what the the starting the
starting comparative point is that
Chinese mortgage institutions these
things that we called yen sales
did a much much better job of protecting
smallholders in the sense that it made
it virtually impossible for them to
default and it made it virtually
impossible for landowner for larger land
landlords they actually seized the left
now this principle question of like why
Darger Lionel landlords rule to tolerate
this kind of thing but this is where the
kind of the political economy that must
come in and that it was actually a Power
Balance kind of thing okay all right
this is where you know this more than
virtually more than any other
institutional context is where
smallholders really face like a
do-or-die kind of situation in that if
they if they lose the institutional
fight over this then very likely all
their land is going to be siphoned off
through defaults and seizures in a
pretty short period of time and they're
just going to become tenants entirely
and whereas landlords had a kind of an
easier thing like they could make
profits even through mortgaging land
under these like somewhat less
hospitable conditions so it was life or
death thing for the small holders but
not quite so much for the landlord's and
so if the small holders have any kind of
political capital whatsoever they're
going to throw it into this kind of
fight right and that's exactly what you
see in China right so they throw you
know they they have Pirkle capital
that's given to them by the nature of
like confusion and kinship priorities
and then they throw it all into these
two fights over tendencies over tenancy
institutions and mortgage institutions
and these are the places where they won
matrons neutral concessions from
landlords and that helps them keep their
lab okay and what are some of your other
findings and how do they play into your
argument right so the the correspond to
a factor is that essentially how much
power small holders have is to a
considerable extent determined by what
are the norms of power allocation within
the society Confucian lineages are at
least nominally Intuit's to consider
books and functionally as well
there jerem toc receipts right okay so
they give out status based on how old
you are and how generationally senior
you are now in this kind of society or
in this kind of early modern society the
life expectancy between rich households
between a rich person in the poor person
very often was out not was not all that
great okay which meant that there were
large numbers of like really a senior
poor
in any given rural community and if you
had norms of static allocation I would
make them high status in high vertical
snatcher then that would mean that in
this community there would exist you
know poor households with quite a bit of
political clout and you know often you
see village chiefs and village headmen
actually being quite poor now this could
never happen in the English context
because they're the social rule
basically was that how much status you
had was directly tied to how much land
you all right so you have in one society
a situation in which you know even
though you could get some power based on
how much land you had there was not an
absolute rule and therefore you know
poor folk could also get a certain
amount of mythical status and power
based on seniority and so on and so
forth so there was a certain there was a
better balance of power that had been in
the English case where the rich guys not
only had all the land they held the
power as well so you know therefore when
it comes to these like major
institutional fights that the poor
really care about the poor have some
political capital to marshal in the
Chinese context whereas they have
virtually none in the English context
okay and I am curious if if in doing
your research did you come across
anything that you didn't expect or
surprised you oh yeah um I I went into
this project not expecting the co2 angle
at all frankly like I when I was in law
school I was initially somewhat enamored
of law and economics and institutional
economics I have a background of
mathematics which makes me kind of like
like quantitative methods and kind of
purely logical mathematical methods so I
went in there expecting that I would to
buy some kind of like law and economics
model for this kind of thing the more I
thought about the more I realized that
had to be incomplete and had they didn't
didn't screw it the sources where you
are there so like this entire cultural
dimension what actually is the core of
the book was something I only added in
after I started doing the archives so
the book changed really fundamentally
from stage from what the planning phase
to how it was later written
okay and what do you conclude in your
book whoa or what are your conclusion
what what so that the broadest possible
level I guess what you could kind of say
is that you know Confucianism is pretty
good for social inequality but the
problem is that in the industrial
in the kind of like economic development
pre-industrial context social equality
may be kind of a bad thing for at least
industrialization okay well in the sense
that insofar as industrialization
depends on large amounts of capital
cumulation and i think that it really
does or this is the thing that I like
this is my angle of getting at this at
this debate other people might emphasize
things like access the coal or you know
constitution of balances and checks or
you know scientific culture and so on
and so forth or demographics or
geography were like how splintered was
the continent how many wars that you
fight my sense is that like
fundamentally everything came back
capital cumulation and insofar as you
know like having the rich accumulate
large amounts of land is one way to get
capital coalition and our new was the
dominant way in England lacking that
that kind of like any unequal
accumulation when paired with certain
other things that also make accumulation
to other means unfeasible is actually a
detriment to economic growth at least at
this period under these kinds of
contexts ease so I guess like the
broadest possible generalization of the
conclusion would be that you know there
are a certain traditional societal
quarters around the world that make
society is more equal but that actually
harmed them over the long run when they
were getting into an arms race what
Western European powers were much less
equal societally but also ironically
birth were therefore able to marshal are
larger much larger amounts of capital
into the abyss transition project so you
get punished for being just very
interesting and I think your your
approach is very novel so we will look
forward to your next book like a
continuation of this journey and I thank
you for being here with us today well
thank you so much for having me okay for
more information about professor Zhang
and his research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you